shoot a video sucre UNICEF avec your
body which was extraordinary Madhavi
with the tillage of new vertical no such
as a promoter failure you know cadet
even nopales you mean if I see on the
levee undermine was it going
[Music]
Bruno declares occurs in Asante steam me
Otto's Street shelter to create a
believe now reply to about was no way
nakisha
this one colleague is prefer her to
tapasya cotton under a table phenomena
we took the validation abuse to a
penalty that was just a former political
it is June we can now avoid a little
don't worry
Sarita the last video tell you we are
clear 64 destroy people
respond schools in touch with
shikaku goes into it
[Music]
watch the girls once that was coming on
to you Bob levitate - OH
[Music]
I thought we plug here
- village screw himself
[Music]
mr. Sakawa
may I present miss Roxanne cause it is a
great pleasure the pleasure's all mine
[Music]
I'm with International Committee of the
Red Cross arguments all political
prisoners must be free it is up to the
government if there is blood it will be
on their hands no one has to die we'll
have to some day
[Music]
he's always smooth by your work he must
love opera
for him he avoids his other
because I'm Sookie calabaza
s paw report
is it true that the government is
considering shooting a song guava
vanilla sized to pin it on the rebels we
need to free your brothers and sisters
we will not surrender to this government
criminals
we here are all they have the gusto la
música we're massa
how did I do we will not last long human
so let her go then we can now more than
four
[Music]
but we'll it's a weekend without them
when they heard the beauty of us perhaps
they will find a solution
[Music]
I think I should sing
[Music]
I want you to sink low enough that these
animals outside can hear
it's time
[Music]
to your knowledge did your father have
any enemies
[Music]
shall I repeat the question no I heard
you
then please answer the new housemaid
ma'am it's Bridget
my name's Lizzie mm-hmm do you find your
room comfortable it can get quite hot up
here sometimes it's best to leave the
door open
sweet thirty doesn't think have I done
something
me losing our edge will eat you
apologize to your mother don't you dare
call her my mother you need me help ya
be certain if you say that Lizzie Andrew
Borden please place your right hand on
the Bible before you do you swear before
Almighty God to tell the truth but all
matters pertaining to the murder of
Andrew and Abby Horton
are you afraid what to your knowledge
did your father have any enemies this is
America sir every man with the pulse has
enemies I'm sick and tired of people
telling me that America is the greatest
country because we can whip your ass I
hate some of these people but I've never
killed
how do you give it with this you're
never gonna be able to unsee what you
saw try to impeach you just try and you
will have a spasm of violence in this
country
like you'd ever say
governor Snyder I got some point water
for you
[Music]
if nobody's gonna do it then I gotta do
it and I will give you you are I'll
fight you in the damn street not now
okay how did this happen the American
Dream is dead stop resisting
the President's powers here are beyond
question
ladies and gentlemen the last President
of the United States
[Music]
coming to an American city near you
my name is Lily Coulson and I'm 18 years
old
these are my three best friends mm Becks
and Sarah and this is the story of how
my town Salem
lost its mind well let's start at the
beginning
dude the principal got hacked
I'll give him like five days before he
commits suicide I'm sorry I just don't
have any sympathy for people that could
hacked for real there's two types of
people in this world people that have
come to terms with privacy is just dead
then there's the old people that are
still trying to fight it what do you
have to hide anyway little a million
nudes super gross porn history and like
super pervy tax about almost everyone at
this school me2 me3 I think it was some
like socially conscious vigilante hacker
guy I live for this type of scandal to
be honest looks like half a salem just
got hacked there's nothing anybody can
do to get these videos down 117 thousand
people's texts and emails get leaked
people get really weird
[Music]
who sees a naked photo of a girl and
their first daughter's yo I gotta kill
this girl way more people than you'd
think
[Applause]
this is your world you built this
don't take your heat out on me I just
got here
may kill me but she can't kill us all
may I introduce to my new wife Colette
the wild days of Danny on the contrary
the wild days have just begun Humana
literary entrepreneur you've married a
country girl fair penny to her name we
do know me Willie is a brand I take all
the risk and the silver money out put
you you could write my school stories
yes yes that could be Willie's next
novel are you writing for him soon yes
he's made you one of his ghosts already
my name is Claudia I live in Montana I
shall probably not die there
is beautiful with never had one fly off
the shelves like this before and who
knows by young women as ever I have a
little plan to turn Claudine into the
most popular girl in the entire world I
believe will you base Cordy on your
school days yes I think I had a little
something to contribute finally we have
a success and then you imply that I'm
not the true author of it people love to
talk I understand the mentality if you
don't I understand it well enough to
write a book there's a toast of Paris
you've done something important all
those young girls we've given them of us
you should own up to it he was after you
your jealousy is misplaced how so it's a
wife I found interesting
we're holding dynamite here that could
blow our bloody heads off since when if
you considered scandal to be a bad thing
oh how interesting your love line splits
into three just get used to marriage
better to make marriage it is to you
people are begging for more I don't want
to write another clue Dean are you out
of your mind right no one can take away
who you are
destroy this incinerate
you found me when I knew nothing
you molded meteor and desires
[Music]
and you thought that I could never break
free
oh you're wrong
and old pen writes history
[Music]
huh we've had a good long run we need to
get out I can open the store together
store this license you walk in the front
door and finish the job
all right
you're not gonna like what comes next
open your safe no never
[Music]
where the sisters brothers FIF ter F my
sister's lugar for many more
it's not like a long employer we have
enough money to stop from good stop what
killing people her father was stark
raving mad and we got his belt blood my
father drank Charlie Touche gentlemen I
have found him I will try to hold him
until your arrival make haste hey is
this warm have it's so interesting
what's the great challenge that all
prospectors face how do I get the goal
just beneath my feet I told you I'm a
chemist norm has a formula you poured in
the river it likes a bull the goal
have you ever tested it
you think it's there yes we're going to
have to fight is you're gonna notice
eventually you're gonna get us yo forget
yourself we're sisters but we're good of
what we do Charlie are you upset I'm
leaving
well Halden you hit me in public Charlie
after I slap you you slapped me back
Craven so then
together two three
[Music]
this organization has seen quite a bit
of you and we really like you and I
believe 100% you're gonna go in the
first round
no I feel like everywhere I go on
reminds me what happened what's happened
about that [ __ ]
and if you wasn't resisting arrest he's
still be so if I resist arrest you're
gonna shoot me I know what you think you
saw starting trouble now toward the
service to everybody one cop goes to a
four now we're all guilty so you say
Larson is just this month's victim I
want to get involved do what you do so
what are the police want with you want
me to keep quiet just saw the tape so
what you're gonna go blab about it
you're gonna make an example out of you
or shadow it's got a new job I'm about
to graduate everything's gonna change if
you just put this out there what would
you do what would you do if somebody
twice your size is coming at you he was
surrounded by six or eight seconds Lisa
dad
[Music]
cities are gonna keep birth
kids are gonna keep getting shot the
cops are gonna keep getting off but you
ever take it out
[Applause]
you have no idea you don't have clue
what goes on on the streets you see
three minutes of a shaky video and you
think you know what you do excuse me I'd
like to open up an account oh great what
type of account do you have in mind this
kind this kind
[Music]
they excuse me need some help no I'm
good let me take a look you know
anything about cars no not really about
you what did you say you do well that's
a secret ever [ __ ] is that
there's only
spent his whole life locked up so for
the times that he broke out he broke out
of San Quentin and eight vote sixteen
successful escapes there's somebody
shoulda told me quit ones in well you
find something you love
[Music]
it's big how I got that from
you think we can pull it off yeah I
think we can probably do it probably
we're gonna be 67 years old I'm gonna
start thinking about my future so how
did the same three guys get away with
all that well haven't gotten away with
that things haven't been caught yet
step on it
just one way stretch out the arms and
cried
just one day guy with a gun
I just got him a funny story
you can catch him myself I hope I get
the chance
ever wonder what I'm doing or where I'm
going I just think of myself as that
little kid I was now what he'd been
proud of me
what is he proud of you another boy oh
he's getting closer every day
[Music]
you